[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com so Sasha Baron Cohen has a
new program on Showtime and if you're
not familiar with Sacha Baron Cohen he
is the guy who previously had the Ali G
show he has a number of characters that
he has played a liji himself Borat
Bruno who what other characters does he
have it was the three I those were the
big guns right he now has a new
character who is an Israeli firearms
instructor and he has pulled off
something pretty stunning that has a lot
of elected officials furious which is
that he went to Capitol Hill again under
the premise of being a pro-gun Israeli
firearms instructor he met with Larry
Pratt from Gun Owners of America who
even if who we've interviewed on the
program before he met with Dana
Rohrabacher and a whole bunch of
different Republican elected officials
maybe some Democrats as well I'm not
totally sure and he got a lot of them to
say they support a program that seeks to
train toddlers to use guns as young as
four or even three years old he got some
of these people to even record videos in
support of the program called I forgot
there's some funny than your guardian
kindergarten kindergarten program lying
that in Israel they have such a program
and now multiple elected officials are
just absolutely furious with him saying
they were duped that the premises of the
entire interview was the premises were
not presented accurately Sarah Palin has
come out and said that she was
interviewed by or met with a supposedly
disabled US veteran who apparently was
also a different Sacha Baron Cohen
character and people are just absolutely
furious with a guy that parts being
disputed though I owe it you know that
would be a fair criticism against Cohen
if he was pretending to be disabled
veteran right you could call that stolen
valor yeah maybe crossing the line but I
guess that's being disputed now I guess
we'll have to wait and well actually see
the interview did you see the disputing
he said that he never said he was a
soldier that he was in the service and
it was a reference to the United Postal
Service Oh or something like that like
that's an actual answer that came
from them huh crossing the line maybe to
some people but it is comedy right which
is always an excuse you can carry in the
back pocket I am like 90% behind what
Sacha Baron Cohen does and 10% kind of
oh I just don't know there's something
about it that I do has to have a
reflexive opposition to in some way but
big picture I think that the guy is
actually a brilliant guy and that some
of the things he does are truly
incredible yeah and you really expose
these Republicans here right they won't
cross the NRA by any means even if it
means advocating for preschoolers and
kindergarteners to carry weapons yes I
mean with Democrats fall for this just
just blindly read something that is
clearly against every very good question
in the defense of Republicans in general
there are some Republicans who refuse to
say I endorse this program there was an
interview that was included in like a
nine minute preview of this show where
he was talking to some Republican
congressman or senator and he asked the
guy to endorse this and he said you're
asking me to say on camera that I
support three-year-olds having guns you
know usually the way it works is members
of Congress don't just support a program
the first time they hear about it
there's a process and then we decide
whether we're gonna endorse it so my
guess is that there were many more
interviews than the ones that ultimately
made it into the show where Republicans
and potentially Democrats alike refused
to do it and they just got edited out
that's my instinct about how it went
yeah like I wonder if a Democrat could
fall for this - certainly not on the
issue of guns but maybe like abortion
right could they have to read something
or like presented with a script that has
to do with partial birth abortions or
abortion after birth and would outside
or whatever yeah they get duped by this
I don't know I'd like to believe the
answer is no but there's prot there's
Republicans and Democrats who will fall
for a lot of things and just because
you're a Democrat doesn't mean you
wouldn't fall for something like this so
yeah I don't think Democrats are are
immune to this type of coercion I gotta
check out this Showtime series so many
cool people interviewed you got Joe
Arpaio you got Dick Cheney who signed
Sacha Baron Cohen's waterboarding kit so
that's pretty cool you gotta check that
out Sarah Palin a lot of members of
Congress a lot of people yeah I I want
to check it out and I think the
the first episode may have already
debuted I don't know if it was last
Sunday or next Sunday that we're gonna
see it but I am it very interested in it
big day for Amazon founder Jeff Bezos
whose net worth briefly surpassed the
one hundred and fifty 1 billion dollar
mark now it feels like it was just
yesterday Pat that we were reporting
that his net worth briefly surpassed 100
billion dollars I think that was in
November of 2017 right so long ago like
7 8 9 months ago I guess at this point
ten months ago and now briefly based on
the market value of Amazon stock briefly
surpassing a hundred and fifty billion
dollars I don't even know what to make
of this you know it's more of course
it's more money than anybody would ever
know what to do with it brings up
broader economic questions about even in
the context not of socialism but of
social democracy is there a benefit to
society from someone having 151 billion
dollars of net worth and I'm not saying
that I'm calling for the seizure of this
money but I am saying that within the
social democratic framework that I
support there would be very reasonable
mechanisms that would allow people to
still become very very rich on the
merits of their entrepreneurship and
innovation but that would make it more
difficult to end up with a hundred and
fifty billion dollars now the counter
would be David it is difficult to end up
with 150 billion because this is the
only only guy who's done it yeah I mean
there are people advocating for like a
billionaires tax where every penny that
you make after a billion dollars is
taxed at a hundred percent and
essentially goes back to the federal
government yeah that would probably be a
better use of that money but certainly
not in line with American values at
least up unto this point the problem
with it just going back to the
government is that I I believe
government is important but there's no
guarantee that government won't just
spend it on wars the further problem
becomes that you need bills taxation
bills or revenue bills those have to be
separate from how the money would be
spent you can't combine it so that
you're sort of taking a risk if you put
in place something like a billionaires
tax tax that the determination as to how
the money is spent has to be done in a
separate bill you could have a different
President or some a different party in
control of Congress at that time and
that stuff can really backfire yeah I my
leanings are not that there should be a
100
tax but I am okay with a very high
marginal tax rate once you get beyond
some amount of money I think a hundred
something feels wrong about a hundred
percent but it could be very high I mean
a ninety percent marginal tax rate above
a billion dollars that doesn't seem
crazy to me it really doesn't when you
come when you think about society and
you're not really hurting someone
standard of living if once they're
earning more than a billion a year
they're paying 90% of it in taxes yet
with income inequality getting so bad or
worse and worse every day we have to
kind of think of some of these solutions
you know there's those statistics about
how you know the richest eight people
own more wealth than the bottom half of
the world combined or whatever the new
statistic is we got to find a path
forward with this stuff and you know I
would like to think that Jeff besos is
being somewhat philanthropic with his
money but there's really not that much
evidence of that you know Bill Gates the
second richest guy gives a lot of money
to charity
yeah billions and billions of dollars
we're not really seeing that too much
with Jeff Bezos and I wonder what it I
can't say whether I just don't know
about his charitable giving so I
wouldn't be able to say whether he
you're familiar with information that he
does not give a lot of money
33 bill 33 million dollars to one
charity which is peanuts compared to his
entire net worth yeah and I don't know
why he would be averse to giving more
right unless it has to do with prestige
maybe he does want to become the first
person to hit a trillion trillion
dollars yeah I don't know read an
interesting article about how he's
increasingly moving in the political
world and spending more and more time in
DC very interesting long-form piece
about about Bezos we talk about
authoritarianism and we often use the
word creeping authoritarianism in the
United States and particularly with some
of the tendencies of our current
president and as I mentioned before
authoritarianism doesn't just show up
one day it does creep slowly but surely
and with President Trump increasingly
we're seeing this by the framing of the
media as the enemy of the people and in
the day before
Trump's summit with Putin he once again
said that the media functions as the
enemy of the people saying unfortunately
no matter how well I do at the summit
which by the way he couldn't possibly
have done worse if I was given the great
city of Moscow as retribution for all
the sins and evils committed by Russia
over the years I would still return to
criticism that it wasn't
that it should have gotten
saint-petersburg in addition much of our
news media is indeed the enemy of the
people and all the Dems know how to do
is resist and obstruct couple things
number one I read a number of pieces
that say that the language in Trump's
tweets in the lead-up to the summit was
clearly not Trump the idea that somebody
else was crafting this messaging because
it just sounds nothing like trump would
say in any case the part that does ring
true is more of these indications of
Trump seeing the media as the enemy of
the people and of course that is
extraordinarily authoritarian and that
is a red flag that should concern
anybody and it's easy to write it off
listen Trump's been talking about fake
news and this and the other thing it's
serious it's serious when you said
george w bush had many problems and i
think the guy was a disastrous president
but he was never wavering in his support
of a free and independent press yeah
it's it's very disrespectful to those
who have lost their lives covering
stories i know you know just about a
month ago or a few weeks ago there was
that shooting in was it maryland at some
journalists office yes and for a while
he was refusing to lower the flags and i
think that's a direct attack on the
media right because he just wants to
ignore them and not give them the
respect that they deserve it's a
consistent lack of respect for media and
playing games with media and it is
extraordin he mostly attacks corporate
media I get that but trickle-down
taxation doesn't work the hostility to
media will trickle down and ultimately
it will be the media outlets with the
least powerful positioning financially
and sort of in the in the milieu of the
media world it's gonna be independent
media that will ultimately get crushed
if you see this concerted hostility from
the Oval Office
combined with net neutrality going going
bye-bye and the consolidation of
corporate media relations a
normalization continues to also make it
so that it's hard to even get reactions
from people about really concerning
actions by the government so I this is a
real problem
that is not being presented as one and I
don't know what the future of it is well
he did offer a caveat right he said much
of
the media not much we are excluded is
that what he was talking about maybe in
Canada media is okay but corporate media
is bad maybe that was what he was trying
to get at
I think he's excluding Fox and Friends
basically that's that's that's weird
what doesn't fall and Hannity's great
awesome Breitbart and The Drudge Report
incredible news organizations yeah
scary stuff and I actually I would be
open to hearing from the audience how do
you fight this war on media because it's
usually fought through media and when
media is what's being attacked its
ability to fight back is compromised
send me your thoughts the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]